La manière dont on étudie la théologie, elle a toujours son importance principale par rapport à son impact, bien sûr, pour notre salut,
mais particulièrement pour l'impact de la manière dont on expérimente ses saluts.
Si les saluts, la rédemption, c'est la réconciliation avec Dieu, c'est la réjouissance des dieux que nous cherchons quand on étudie la théologie.
Et voilà pourquoi j'ai fait cet avertissement constamment.
On ne doit pas perdre de vue cet aspect relationnel, expérimental de la révélation biblique, car l'intérêt des dieux, c'est de révéler son amour pour nous.
Ce qu'on connaisse, c'est qu'on connaisse avec expérience la profondeur, la largeur, la hauteur de l'amour des dieux révélés en Christ.
C'est la profondeur des richesses.
Donc quand on étudie la théologie, c'est important de préserver cette attitude, car parfois on est tenté, soit par tradition, soit pour vouloir avoir raison, soit par habitude, soit par prise de position.
Parfois on est tenté à rester accroché à une tradition, à une théorie, pour plusieurs raisons.
Et la réalité, c'est que les soins avec lesquels on devrait utiliser et étudier la théologie, c'est les soins sous les risques d'offenser cette condescendance glorieuse des dieux.
Car s'il est en train de nous révéler quelque chose de glorieuse, l'évangile, c'est car ça, c'est précieux pour lui.
Et c'est précieux pour lui pour qu'on ait la bonne connaissance, pour avoir la bonne expérience.
Et donc les divergences peuvent rester légitimes.
Mais l'attitude avec laquelle on étudie la théologie, elle est plus importante.
Et donc, quand on lit et quand on étudie la théologie des alliances,
ou les plans de rédemption de l'alliance des dieux avec l'homme,
donc le chapitre 7 de l'alliance des dieux avec l'homme,
on est en train de nous approfondir dans les manières particulières dont Dieu a révélé les points de la rénonçant.
Donc nous pouvons résumer de manière très concise, avec vérité et précision.
Nous sommes sauvés par la personne et l'œuvre du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et ça peut suffire pour nous sauver.
Par contre, les plus on se plonge dans la personne du Seigneur Jésus-Christ et dans l'œuvre de la rédemption,
les plus on grandit dans la réjouissance et dans l'adoration de ces choses.
Et donc, c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire avec la confession de foi.
Nous allons juste faire un rappel des trois paragraphes devant lesquels nous sommes.
Et donc, les titres de ces chapitres, c'est de l'alliance des dieux avec l'homme.
Et il y a un titre qui va apparaître, c'est ce qu'on appelle l'alliance des grâces.
Et nous allons comprendre en fait que l'expression alliance des grâces n'est pas une expression biblique.
C'est une expression biblique dans le sens où c'est une conclusion biblique d'utiliser ces titres pour décrire cette seule alliance.
Mais la réalité, c'est que quand on lit les trois paragraphes, on est en train de voir trois alliances distinctes qui sont là.
Les termes alliance, oui, il est très biblique, il apparaît plus de 300 fois dans la parole des dieux.
Par contre, alliance des grâces est un titre que les théologiens ont donné, avec précision comme on verra.
Mais pour l'instant, les premiers paragraphes, ils parlent de quelle alliance ?
L'alliance des vies, merci Loïc.
Donc l'alliance de la création, l'alliance avant la chute.
Et on se rappelle en fait que quelque part c'est une nécessité que cette relation des dieux envers les hommes soit une relation d'alliance.
Et il y a une intentionnalité de la part des baptistes, donc les premiers baptistes qui ont rédigé la confession.
Ils ont voulu ne pas utiliser l'expression la plus populaire de cette alliance avant la chute, l'alliance des œuvres.
Pour nous rappeler qu'ils, même dans les cadres de l'alliance des œuvres, ils n'étaient pas contraires à la compréhension alliance des œuvres.
Ils étaient contraires à un titre qui pourrait supprimer la conception des grâces même dans l'alliance des œuvres.
Donc Dieu a été condescendant, Dieu n'était pas obligé à établir une alliance avec l'homme à point de lui donner l'opportunité d'élever sa condition qui était déjà parfaite à une condition plus que parfaite.
Et donc il y a de la grâce même dans cette alliance où Dieu va enlever l'homme de là où il a été créé pour l'enserrer dans un lieu privilégié d'intimité avec Dieu, l'aidant.
Et à partir de là, établir un niveau de relation avec Dieu qui soit un niveau encore plus gracieux.
Donc ensuite, ça montre en fait qu'après la chute au paragraphe 2, et là c'est une autre alliance qu'on va aborder, mais chronologiquement, c'est le paragraphe 3 qui apparaît en premier.
Donc ça, c'est la manière de considérer l'alliance que Dieu a établie avec les fils dans l'éternité.
L'alliance éternelle, si vous voulez, c'est un titre qu'on utilise pour décrire cette alliance où on utilise l'expression de la transaction pactuelle éternelle des dieux.
Donc là, c'est important pour nous, comme on verra, j'espère, à la fin de ces études sur les alliances, les glorieux mystères de cette alliance qui a été d'abord et avant tout établie avec Christ.
Les pères établissant cette alliance avec Christ avant la fondation du monde.
C'est qu'il y a de manière mystérieuse, va même comprendre cette alliance adamique avant la chute dans ces grands plans éternels des dieux.
Mais c'est intéressant de remarquer que là, on a aussi cette alliance qui était la première.
Et dans l'étang dans l'espace, après l'alliance d'Adam avoir échoué, donc par nécessité, si jamais on allait avoir la possibilité de la rédemption, ça serait par grâce.
Car une fois que nous avons perdu notre état d'innocence et souffert la conséquence de cette séparation des dieux, l'être humain n'est plus en mesure de satisfaire les exigences des dieux.
Par coupabilité et par corruption.
Et donc à partir de là, si jamais il y a l'espoir pour l'humanité, à part la destination absolue à l'enfer, c'est si jamais Dieu fait quelque chose à la faveur de l'homme.
Et s'il est fait, nécessairement, si ce n'est plus possible par nos mérites, c'est une alliance des grâces.
Donc à partir de la chute d'Adam, c'est impossible de considérer qu'aucune alliance qui Dieu aurait pu établir avec l'humanité soit une alliance d'autre chose qu'est grâce.
Ok ?
Question logique et c'est ça que les paragraphes 2 veulent mettre en évidence.
Par nécessité, d'un côté, et après par intentionnalité, par délibération divine.
Dieu a voulu établir cette alliance des grâces, cette alliance est décrite comme une alliance des grâces.
Donc même si les titres de cette alliance, l'alliance des grâces, n'est pas là,
nous savons qu'à chaque fois que l'apôtre Paul et les auteurs du Nouveau Testament, y compris Christ,
vont faire référence à cette alliance, qu'elle touche l'Ancien Testament ou les Nouveaux,
à chaque fois qu'une alliance qui a eu lieu après la chute, elle est décrite comme une alliance des grâces.
Elle est décrite en faisant, usage surtout de l'expression promesse,
où nous voyons que la promesse des dieux, c'était de sauver son peuple,
de faire un peuple pour soi et d'être Dieu pour ces peuples-là.
Et donc, quand on va étudier, même si de manière ponctuelle et particulière,
chacune de ces alliances, l'alliance avec Noé, l'alliance avec David, l'alliance avec Adam après la chute,
l'alliance avec Moïse et l'alliance avec Abraham,
nous allons à chaque fois identifier ces éléments des grâces qui vont décrire cette alliance établie par Dieu.
Par nécessité et par contexte explicité.
Donc, ça fait que, même si les titres « Alliance des grâces » soient un titre qui représente une conception théologique,
la conception théologique, elle reste biblique,
car même si les titres n'est pas la explicite,
la description biblique et les contextes montrent clairement
que c'était une alliance des promesses,
une alliance de ceux qui étaient opposés au mérite,
une alliance donc des grâces.
Donc, la substance a toujours été l'alliance des grâces.
Donc, c'est quoi l'alliance des grâces ?
Pour revenir en rappel de la définition,
l'alliance des grâces,
c'est donc une conception théologique comme la Trinité,
qui n'est pas en termes bibliques,
mais nous arrivons à cette conclusion par la précision de nos études bibliques.
Et donc, elle est biblique dans sa précision,
mais pas biblique dans son expression,
mais l'alliance des grâces sont les promesses assermentées des dieux
de racheter l'empêcheur.
Donc, c'est Dieu qui va jurer qu'il va sauver l'empêcheur
et il les fait par grâce.
Donc, c'est en termes des promesses.
Ces promesses se sont révélées progressivement par Dieu
les langues de l'histoire.
Ils sont fondés dans les plans éternels des dieux
de sauver un peuple pour soi.
Pourquoi c'est une alliance, donc, des grâces ?
Elle reçoit ces noms car elle a la grâce pour origine.
C'était la grâce des dieux qui a voulu développer ces plans pour nous.
Ce sont les richesses de la grâce des dieux.
Elle a pour contenu, pour nature ou pour substance, la grâce.
C'est la grâce qui va permettre cette alliance.
Et le but ultime de cette alliance est de rendre gloire à la grâce des dieux.
Pour ceux qui ne participent pas à cette alliance,
donc les impénitents, les injustes, les réprobre,
Dieu va glorifier sa justice.
Romain, chapitre 9.
Les vases des colères serviront à la manifestation de la gloire,
de la justice des dieux, de la puissante justice des dieux.
Ok ? La toute puissante justice des dieux.
Par contre, sur les vases des miséricordes ou des grâces,
c'est la grâce des dieux qui sera glorifiée.
D'accord ?
Voilà pourquoi on appelle cette alliance, alliance des grâces.
Donc, on va lire les paragraphes 2 et 3.
Bien plus, puisque l'homme s'est placé sous la malédiction de la loi par sa chute,
il a plu au Seigneur de faire une alliance des grâces,
dans laquelle il offre gratuitement aux pécheurs la vie
et les salue par Jésus-Christ,
requérant d'eux la foi en lui pour être sauvé.
Il y promet en eau de donner son Saint-Esprit ou son Esprit Saint
à tous ceux qui sont destinés à la vie éternelle
pour les rendre désireux et capables de croire.
Ok ?
Donc, description de l'alliance des grâces singuliers.
C'est-à-dire, tout ce qui se passe en termes de relation des dieux avec l'homme
au lieu de nous envoyer directement l'enfer,
après la chute,
s'appelle alliance des grâces.
Paragraphe 3, comment cette alliance des grâces a été révélée ?
Cette alliance est révélée dans l'Évangile,
tout d'abord à Adam,
intéressant, important,
la phraseologie, si vous voulez, de la confession.
Cette alliance est révélée dans l'Évangile.
Ok ?
Donc, l'Évangile singulier,
tout d'abord à Adam.
Donc, l'Évangile était déjà prêché à Adam,
les mêmes Évangiles.
Ok ?
Dans la promesse du salut par la postérité de la femme,
et par la suite progressivement,
jusqu'à sa révélation complète dans les Nouveaux Testaments.
Elle est, donc voilà, les grands mystères glorieux,
elle est fondée dans l'alliance,
ou dans la transaction éternelle
entre les pères et les fils concernant la rédemption des élus.
Ce n'est pas, pardon,
ce n'est qu'est par la grâce de cette alliance
que tout membre de la postérité d'Adam,
déchu,
a jamais été sauvé,
et a obtenu la vie
et la bienheureuse immortalité,
puisque maintenant,
l'homme est complètement incapable d'être accepté par Dieu
dans les conditions qui étaient valables pour Adam
dans son état d'innocence.
Donc, le texte, il est très clair,
et nous allons continuer de nous approfondir aujourd'hui
par un autre aspect de cette alliance.
Donc, on avance.
C'était un schéma qui nous montrait
la même alliance,
une seule alliance des grâces,
révélée progressivement,
administrée par deux dispensations principales,
l'ancienne dans l'Ancien Testament
et la nouvelle dans les Nouveaux Testaments.
Ok ?
Donc, on avance,
ça c'est juste un rappel.
Donc,
ok,
donc c'est là,
la leçon d'aujourd'hui,
c'est là où nous allons nous concentrer.
Nous allons traiter aujourd'hui
l'alliance des grâces dans le Nouveau Testament.
Car nous avons,
dans les dernières leçons,
nous avons travaillé
pour considérer l'alliance de l'Ancien Testament
en démontrant que chacune d'entre elles
était une alliance des grâces en soi,
pour nous aider à comprendre
ce qui les unissait entre elles
et comprendre,
notamment,
qu'est-ce qui est la définition biblique d'une alliance
et notamment d'une alliance des grâces.
Donc,
cette considération,
ça nous a servi,
notamment,
d'identifier
ces conclusions de la confession de foi.
Donc,
il y a une seule
et même alliance des grâces
qui a été révélée
ou administrée
sous deux grandes dispensations,
l'Ancien Testament
et le Nouveau Testament.
Dans le Nouveau Testament,
tout a été pleinement révélé,
tout a été rempli
et donc,
on n'a pas de progression,
des révélations,
car nous sommes arrivés
à la révélation ultime
de toutes les choses.
Par contre,
dans l'Ancien Testament,
il y a eu une révélation progressive
de l'Alliance des grâces.
Et donc,
aujourd'hui,
on va se concentrer surtout
sur les premiers points qu'il y a là.
Donc,
pourquoi Nouvelle Alliance ?
c'est la question
qu'on doit se poser.
Donc,
là,
on dit que la Nouvelle Alliance
est nouvelle.
Ce n'est pas car
elle est complètement
ou toute nouvelle.
Ce n'est pas car
on est en train de considérer
une rupture radicale
entre la Nouvelle Alliance
et l'Ancienne Alliance.
Donc,
on a beau travailler
pour considérer,
la confession est explicite
et claire,
à partir du moment
où il y a eu la chute,
c'est impossible
que l'homme préserve
aucune relation avec Dieu
qui ne soit pas fondée
sur la grâce.
Et toutes ces alliances
sont par nécessité
des alliances des grâces,
mais elles sont aussi
alliances des grâces
car Dieu a voulu
les établir.
OK ?
Et donc,
une seule alliance,
une alliance des grâces
dans l'Ancienne Alliance
et dans la Nouvelle Alliance.
Donc,
la Bible,
elle a une préoccupation
plus expérimentale
dans la révélation des choses.
Donc,
juste pour utiliser
un autre exemple,
sans vouloir ouvrir
une fenêtre à cet égard,
quand on pense
à l'interaction
entre la souveraineté
des dieux
et la responsabilité humaine,
parfois,
les personnes
qui veulent,
voilà,
développer
une notion
de l'élection
qui puisse
être saisie
par la pensée humaine,
donc,
ce sont des choses
qui nous dépassent,
bien sûr,
et nous devons être humbles
pour accepter
la révélation biblique,
mais,
les personnes
vont s'accrocher
à la notion
de la préscience
des dieux,
dieux qui connaît
d'avance
les choses,
comme si Dieu,
il avait vu
que certaines personnes
allaient accepter,
donc il a choisi
car il a su
que ces personnes
allaient accepter.
Déjà,
ça annule complètement
la grâce des dieux
car c'est basé
sur les mérites
de la personne
qui a choisi pour dieux.
OK ?
Je ne vais pas rentrer
ou rester là trop dedans.
C'est juste pour vous montrer
comment,
parfois,
on s'accroche
à cette conception
sans la définir
bibliquement
car selon la Bible,
rien que l'expression
connaître d'avance
dans l'Ancien Testament
et l'usage du nouveau
cherche à exploiter
la même signification,
ce n'est pas
une connaissance
tout simplement théorique.
Ce n'est pas
une connaissance
à distance.
Lorsque la Bible dit
ce qui Dieu
a connu d'avance,
ce sont des personnes
avec qui Dieu
est rentré
en relation.
C'est toujours
expérimental,
c'est toujours
relationnel.
Et donc,
cette connaissance
d'avance
a à voir
avec le travail
et l'œuvre
que Dieu a dû faire
dans ces personnes
afin qu'elles soient capables,
comme la confession
le dit clairement,
même de croire,
même d'expérimenter
la vraie répentance.
Et de toute manière,
la doctrine
des décrets éternels
des dieux
font que
cette préscience
des dieux
ne soit pas basée
tout simplement
dans les savoirs
en avance,
mais sur les faits
que c'est Dieu lui-même,
les dieux de la providence,
les dieux de la création,
les dieux qui gouvernent
et qui mettent à terme
ses plans.
Donc,
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui est en train
de gouverner
toutes les choses
qui se passent
dans l'univers.
Donc,
c'est juste la parenthèse
pour vous montrer
que quand on considère
cette question
des alliances,
nous sommes devant
une question similaire.
Donc,
on est devant
une seule alliance
des grâces.
J'ai perdu
les fils conducteurs.
Désolé.
Ça arrive.
Quelle serait la connexion ?
La Bible a un développement
beaucoup plus expérimental.
Voilà, merci.
Et donc,
connaître d'avance
l'aspect expérimental
messiloïque
a à voir
avec cette connaissance.
Pourquoi Dieu va utiliser
l'expression
cette expression
nouvelle alliance ?
Ce n'est pas forcément
pour qu'on soit
tout simplement
théorique et littéraire
dans cette expression nouvelle
car l'enseignement clair
des écritures
et on ne peut pas
contredire les écritures,
c'est,
comme on verra,
qu'il y a
la même substance,
il y a la même grâce
qui va permettre
les deux dispensations,
la réjouissance
des mêmes bénédictions.
Et donc,
lorsque la Bible
elle parle
de la nouvelle alliance,
nous devons chercher
à considérer
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
des nouveaux
dans la nouvelle alliance.
Et si
la nouvelle alliance
et l'ancienne alliance
sont décrites
avec la même essence
commune,
et si c'est un enseignement
nécessaire de la Bible
que toutes les alliances
des dieux avec l'homme
après la chute
sont par grâce divine,
nous ne pouvons pas considérer
que la nouvelle alliance
soit complètement nouvelle
ou totalement nouvelle
dans un sens
des ruptures radicales,
mais plutôt
dans un sens,
comme on verra,
d'intensité,
des plénitudes,
des réjouissances.
Donc,
on peut dire
que c'est vraiment nouveau
surtout par rapport
au niveau
des réjouissances,
d'intensité
des révélations
et de plusieurs autres égards,
comme on verra.
Mais donc,
la nouvelle,
il parle
de la dispensation,
de l'administration.
Donc,
juste pour donner un exemple,
la lourdeur
de cette
accumulation progressive
de tous ces types
qui devraient pointer
envers Christ
a amené
la fin de l'histoire
de la religion juive,
une religion très lourde,
avec toute cette difficulté
pour s'approcher
des dieux,
avec les lois cérémonielles,
les lois des tabernacles,
les lois des purifications,
les jours qu'il faut garder
etc.
Et nous savons très bien
que dans notre réjouissance
pratique
de la nouvelle alliance,
nous voyons
cette simplicité
d'un culte
où nous avons
les pans,
les vents,
l'eau et la parole.
Vous comprenez ?
La simplicité des choses.
Donc,
ce qu'il y a de nouveau,
c'est
cette réjouissance
effective,
mais pas
la substance
des alliances
qui reste
la substance
de la grâce.
Et donc,
les trois points
qu'on verra
d'ici vers l'avant,
c'est pourquoi
nouvelle alliance
je vais vous expliquer
et à partir de là,
nous devons poser
ces trois questions
ou exploiter
ces trois aspects.
Aujourd'hui,
on va se concentrer
sur les premiers points.
Il y a une seule
et même alliance.
quelles sont les évidences
qui nous montrent
que l'ancienne alliance
était de la même nature
que la nouvelle alliance.
Pourquoi nous devons
insister
et comment nous pouvons
constater dans la parole
de Dieu
qu'il s'agit
d'une seule alliance ?
Donc,
pour empêcher
que la discontinuité
entre l'ancienne
et la nouvelle
soit une rupture
qui puisse blesser
cette unité.
et dans les prochaines leçons,
on va considérer
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de nouveau
ou la supériorité
de la nouvelle alliance
par rapport à l'ancienne.
C'est bon jusque-là ?
Ok.
Donc,
prochain slide.
Ok.
Donc là,
on va se concentrer
sur ces points
aujourd'hui.
et donc,
l'ancienne
et la nouvelle alliance
sont une seule
et même alliance
des grâces
et nous posons la question
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
des communs
entre ces deux dispensations ?
Nous allons lire
beaucoup de passages
ensemble
et là,
on va rester
sur ces slides
jusqu'à la fin
aujourd'hui
mais si vous voulez
suivre dans vos bibles,
je vais vous citer
et vous lire
plusieurs passages.
Donc,
la première chose
ou les premiers aspects
qu'on doit considérer
c'est que les deux alliances,
l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance
ou les deux dispensations
de cette même alliance
ont la même
grande promesse
ou la promesse principale
est la même.
C'est celle qu'on retrouve
en Genèse,
chapitre 17,
verset 8.
Je serai votre Dieu.
Ça,
c'est la plus grande
de toutes les bénédictions
pouvoir dire
mon Dieu.
Ça,
c'est tout simplement
les privilèges ultimes
de tous les êtres humains
et c'était un privilège
qui représentait déjà
la promesse des dieux
pour Israël
dans l'Ancien Testament.
Donc,
les Nouveaux Testaments,
ils confirment
cette promesse centrale
de l'alliance des grâces
telle qu'elle a été promise
dans l'ancienne dispensation.
Donc,
dans les proto-évangiles,
c'est-à-dire
depuis,
après la chute,
en Genèse,
chapitre 3,
verset 15,
nous voyons
que la promesse,
même si elle n'est pas
explicite comme ça,
c'est évidente
de toute manière.
Donc,
je mettrai
l'inimitié
entre toi et la femme,
c'est-à-dire
entre les diables,
l'inimitié avec Dieu
a eu pour source
l'amitié de la femme
avec les diables.
Et la promesse des dieux,
par grâce,
totalement par grâce,
c'est
la réconciliation
avec Dieu
aura lieu.
Dieu
redéviendra
à être
les dieux
de l'humanité
car Dieu
mettrait
de l'inimitié
entre la femme
et les serpents,
entre la postérité
du serpent
et entre la postérité
de la femme.
Celle-ci,
c'est-à-dire
la postérité
de la femme,
t'écrasera la tête
et tu lui blesseras
les talents.
Donc,
nous savons tous
aujourd'hui
par les privilèges
de la nouvelle alliance
que cette promesse
est exactement la même
car elle s'accomplit
en Jésus-Christ.
C'est cette promesse
qui a été promise
dans l'Ancien Testament
depuis le proto-évangile.
C'est la promesse
de la réconciliation
avec Dieu.
Dieu serait à nouveau
notre Dieu
à travers
la provision
d'un descendant
de la femme
qui viendrait écraser
la tête du serpent,
qui allait finir
définitivement
avec cette œuvre
du serpent.
Et donc,
la promesse
est la réconciliation
avec Dieu.
Quand on arrive
à Noé,
au chapitre 9,
verset 8,
à 17,
je vais juste
vous présenter
quelques versets.
Et Dieu dit à Noé
et à ses fils
avec lui,
« Voici,
j'établis mon alliance
avec vous
et avec votre postérité
après vous
et avec tous
les êtres vivants
qui sont avec vous.
J'ai placé mon arc
dans la nuit
et il servira
des signes
de cette alliance
entre moi
et la terre. »
Donc,
jusqu'ici,
c'est une alliance
plus générale,
globale,
mais c'est intéressant,
cela est enrichi
avec une définition
plus claire
de cette promesse
de Dieu
qui redéviendra
être les dieux
du peuple
de la postérité
de la foi
d'Adam et Ève.
Donc,
qui est ce peuple-là ?
Genèse 9,
25,
il y a eu
cet épisode
d'immoralité
sexuelle
envers Noé
par rapport
à ses enfants
et il y a
cette maudition
entre les enfants
et c'est très important
de remarquer
depuis les versets 25
du chapitre 9
et il dit
« Maudit soit Canaan,
qu'il soit l'esclave
des esclaves
de ses frères »
et donc là,
on a à nouveau
cette division
entre toute la race humaine
représentée
par la postérité
sous l'influence
de la rébellion,
de Satan
et la postérité
sous l'influence
de la foi.
Donc,
qui serait
la descendance
d'où viendra
notamment
la formation
d'Israël ?
Donc,
notamment,
nous savons très bien,
donc l'alliance
est établie
surtout
avec Sème.
Donc,
béni soit l'éternel
Dieu des Sème.
Donc,
attention,
Dieu des Sème.
OK ?
Dieu
d'une personne
qui représente un peuple
et Dieu d'un peuple.
OK ?
Et nous savons
que la descendance
des Sème,
c'est la descendance
de la femme,
de la foi de la femme
et de la foi d'Adam.
Mais ce qui est intéressant,
c'est même si
Israël biologique
vient de la descendance
des Sème,
nous allons constater,
donc là,
et qu'il soit son esclave,
verset 27,
et que Dieu
étende les possessions
déjà faites,
qu'il habite
dans les tentes
des Sèmes
et que Canaan
soit leur esclave.
Donc,
quelle est
l'implication
scatologique
pour tout ça ?
C'est que Japhète
représente
toutes les autres nations
et les tentes
des Sèmes
seront étendues,
OK ?
en seul peuple,
les peuples
des dieux,
à travers
un peuple premier
en touchant
toutes les autres nations.
OK ?
Mais Dieu
sera les peuples.
Dieu aura son peuple,
sera les dieux
de son peuple.
Donc,
la même promesse.
Quand on arrive
à Abraham,
c'est encore plus clair
et explicite.
Bien sûr,
quand on arrive à Abraham,
pour vous rappeler,
même si ces choses
étaient déjà implicites
depuis Adam
et Ève,
OK ?
avec la promesse,
ça devient explicite
à partir d'Abraham.
C'est là
où Dieu va
couper l'alliance
de manière
la plus explicitement formelle
et la plus fondamentale.
D'accord ?
Aucune des alliances
qui viendraient après
ne pourraient contredire
ou suggérer
aucune rupture.
Elle serait toujours
subserviente
et de la même nature
que cette.
C'est l'argument
de Paul en Galate,
chapitre 3.
Donc,
ici,
nous voyons
l'alliance établie
avec Abraham.
Genèse 12,
1 à 3.
Je ferai de toi
une grande nation,
je te bénirai
et je rendrai
ton nom grand
et tu seras
une source de bénédiction,
je bénirai
ceux qui te béniront
et je maudirai
ceux qui te maudiront
et toutes les familles
de la terre
seront bénies
en toi.
Vous voyez ?
Les échos
de ce qui a été dit
par rapport
à Japhé
et à Sèdre.
OK ?
Un homme
à travers qui
les Messies
viendraient,
toute sa postérité
serait bénie
et toutes les nations
bénies
dans la postérité
d'Abraham.
OK ?
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Genèse 17,
7 et 8.
J'établirai
mon alliance
entre moi et toi
et ta postérité
après toi
selon leur génération
en alliance
perpétuelle
pour être ton Dieu
et les dieux
de ta postérité
après toi
et je te donnerai
à toi
et à ta postérité
après toi
les pays
où tu es étranger.
Et donc là,
quelle est la promesse
de l'alliance des grâces ?
C'est Dieu
avec son peuple
dans les lieux
des dieux.
Les peuples des dieux
en communion avec Dieu
dans les lieux des dieux.
Donc c'est important
de nous rappeler
de ce qui est central
dans la promesse
« J'essayerai votre Dieu ».
Et pourquoi c'est important ?
Car jusqu'aujourd'hui,
on peut être tenté
à cibler plus
Dieu
comme source
de tous les biens
mais parfois
on oublie
que Dieu
est bien suprême.
La relation avec Dieu
Donc même si
l'alliance
peut comprendre
des bénédictions temporelles,
la terre des prospérités,
elle est plutôt centrée
sur le fait
que Dieu
est notre Dieu.
OK ?
Donc avec Moïse,
c'est très intéressant
et très important
pour les discussions
sur les alliances
car même l'alliance
établie avec Moïse,
elle est établie
dans les cadres
ou les prologues
en Exode chapitre 19
verset 3 à 6.
Dieu,
il arrive pour dire
« Vous serez pour moi
un royaume des prêtres,
une nation sainte,
vous serez mon peuple
particulier
parmi tous les peuples. »
Donc Dieu
avec Moïse,
il traite déjà
Israël
comme son premier-né.
Et dans cette introduction,
Dieu va dire
« Je vous ai délivré
l'Égypte
sur mes ailes.
Je vous ai enlevé l'Égypte. »
C'est-à-dire
les saluts
typifiés
par la Pâque
étaient déjà
accomplis.
Et là,
un peuple libéré
est en train
d'établir
une alliance
dans un cadre
déjà
des grâces,
des libérations
et qui met
l'emphase
notamment
sur ces points
où Dieu
veut faire
d'Israël
une nation
particulière
parmi tous les peuples.
Un peuple
qui devient
son trésor personnel.
Donc vous voyez
la manière
dont Dieu
nous voit
lorsqu'il établit
une alliance
formelle
avec chaque individu
chrétien
et avec tous
les chrétiens
en tant que peuples,
peuples
des propriétés
particulières
de Dieu.
Le langage
c'est comme si
un roi
avait certains
objets
chez lui
qui étaient
particulièrement
d'usage personnel
qu'il aime bien,
précieux,
etc.
Et donc David
on voit la même
promesse aussi
non seulement
par cette dynastie
messianique
mais l'emphase
mise
particulièrement
sur l'intimité.
Et ici
les langages
il va surmonter
cette relation
Dieu
avec son peuple
pour arriver
à cette relation
entre Dieu
les pères,
Dieu notre père
et nous
ses enfants.
Donc naturellement
verset 11
du chapitre
pardon 17
chronique 17
verset 11
quand tes jours
seront accomplis
et qu'ils tuiraient
auprès de tes pères
je lèverai ta
postérité
après toi
l'un de tes fils
et j'affirmerai
son règne.
Ce sera lui
qui me bâtira
une maison
et j'affirmerai
pour toujours
son trône.
Je serai pour lui
un père
et il sera
pour moi
un fils
et je ne lui
retirerai
point ma grâce
comme j'ai retiré
à celui
qui t'a précédé.
j'établirai
pour toujours
dans ma maison
et dans mon royaume
je l'établirai
pour toujours
dans ma maison
et dans mon royaume
et son trône
sera pour toujours
affirmé.
Donc ici
nous devons apprendre
à faire
ce qu'on appelle
l'interprétation prophétique
les transpositions prophétiques
car nous savons
très bien
comme pour Abraham
avec l'aide
des Galates
et avec l'aide
de Jésus
pour ses passages
que cette promesse
d'un descendant
qui régnerait
pour toujours
n'était pas
forcément
la promesse
qui parlait
du fils
qui a construit
les temples
littéraux.
Donc on sait très bien
qui a construit
la maison
qui a bâti
c'était
Salomon
mais
Jésus lui-même
il dit
détruisez
ces temples
en trois jours
je les rébâtis
et c'est sur ça
dont la promesse
parlait déjà
c'est la
la reconstruction
du temple
spirituel
qui représentait
la résurrection
du Christ
et tous les chrétiens
en Jésus
unis
en tant
qu'est
pervivante
formant
ce rituel
pour Dieu
c'est Christ
lui-même
qui nous aide
d'interpréter
l'accomplissement
partiel
avec
Salomon
mais Salomon
n'a pas
régné
pour toujours
Christ
il règne
pour toujours
et donc
les textes
parlaient déjà
de cette relation
une relation
entre père
et fils
et nous
en Jésus
nous sommes
les fils
des dieux
pas
tout simplement
dans les pluriel
on a cette implication
aussi
les enfants
des dieux
mais nous sommes
un Christ
et donc nous sommes
aimés comme Christ
lui-même
en tant qu'enfant
des dieux
vous voyez
le pacte ici
est établi
l'alliance est établie
déjà en ciblant
le Seigneur Jésus
on voit aussi
cette transition
qui fait Jérémie
envers la nouvelle alliance
et les langages
il est là
déjà certain
de faire la connexion
entre la même promesse
qui a été faite
à l'ancienne alliance
et donc
accomplie
parfaitement
dans la nouvelle
donc quand on passe
au Nouveau Testament
on voit
toute la
confirmation
en fait
que l'alliance
ou la promesse
d'alliance
était la même
donc lorsqu'on arrive
à Galate
l'apôtre Paul va dire
au chapitre 3
verset 14
afin que la bénédiction
d'Abraham
eue pour les gentils
ou pour les païens
en Jésus Christ
et que nous ressuscions
par la foi
l'esprit
qui avait été promis
or les promesses
verset 16
ont été faites
à Abraham
et à sa postérité
donc ici
les langages
sont les mêmes
il ne dit pas
et aux postérités
donc là
ce n'était pas
une promesse
automatique
à toute la descendance
et toutes les générations
des Israéliens
même s'il y a eu
une implication
prophétique
temporelle
pour ça
des bénédictions
temporelles
pour Israël
et des jugements
temporels
pour Israël
par contre
la promesse
était toujours faite
à Abraham
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc Christ
il va à chaque fois
ressortir
comme celui
à qui Dieu
fait la promesse
même si on a vu
que la promesse
a été faite à Adam
la promesse a été faite
aux descendants
d'Adam
qui allaient écraser
la tête du serpent
on rentre déjà
dans le troisième aspect
c'est mystère
où Christ est toujours
les principaux
et les premiers
médiateurs
mais nous voyons
aussi
qu'il y avait
toujours un aspect
qui s'accomplissait aussi
dans les contextes
de chaque promesse
mais ici
Paul est en train de dire
ce n'est pas
aux postérités
comme en parlant
de plusieurs
mais comme en parlant
d'un seul
à ta postérité
qui est Christ
c'est-à-dire
ces promesses
elles n'aboutissent
pas à son sens spirituel
pour l'Ancien Testament
et pour nouveau
qui est pour ceux
qui ont la foi d'Abraham
ceux qui ont la foi
dans les Messies
promis
en Christ
donc la même promesse
est là
et donc la promesse
du fait
que Dieu serait
les dieux
non seulement
des juifs
mais aussi
les dieux
des païens
donc si vous êtes
en Christ
c'est la conclusion
de Paul
si vous êtes en Christ
vous êtes donc
la postérité d'Abraham
héritier
selon la promesse
c'est clair pour vous
donc il n'y a pas
cette distinction
qu'on essaye de faire
jusqu'aujourd'hui
à cause de certaines
positions scatologiques
comme si Israël
restait quelque part
plus important
car depuis Galate
la bataille d'Abraham
c'est non
la descendance d'Abraham
et la descendance
de la foi
c'est qu'il y a
le plus important
qui est en train
de se passer
aujourd'hui
n'est pas
ce qui est en train
de se passer
en Palestine
ou Israël
c'est ce qui est en train
de se passer ici
dans les églises
qui proclament
l'évangile de Jésus-Christ
ok
et donc
la même promesse
est appliquée
à l'église
composée des croyants
juifs et païens
et ça c'est explicite
aussi dans le Nouveau Testament
2e Corinthiens 6
car nous sommes
les temples
de Dieu vivant
donc à nouveau
pour réconfirmer
l'interprétation correcte
de la promesse
faite à David
à travers Salomon
à Christ
et donc ici
nous voyons
de manière très claire
car nous sommes
les temples
de Dieu vivant
selon ce qui Dieu a dit
j'habiterai
et je marcherai
au milieu d'eux
et j'esserai leur Dieu
et ils seront
mon peuple
2e Corinthiens 6
donc c'est Paul
qui nous aide
à comprendre
quelle était
cette promesse
dans l'Ancien Testament
Hébreu 8
car voici l'alliance
que je ferai
avec la maison d'Israël
après ces jours-là
dit le Seigneur
je mettrai
mes lois
dans leur esprit
pardon
mes lois dans leur esprit
et j'écrirai
dans leur cœur
et j'esserai
leur Dieu
et ils seront
mon peuple
donc là c'est la citation
de Jérémie 31
et donc c'est la manière
dont la liaison
entre la même promesse
est explicitement faite
par l'auteur
de Hébreu
Romain 4
donc on n'a pas
le temps de tout relire
mais c'est l'un des passages
les plus importants
pour identifier
ces mêmes promesses
réjouites
dans l'Ancien Testament
dans les Nouveaux
il reçut
les signes
de la circoncision
saut de la justice
de la foi
qu'il avait
pendant qu'il était
en circoncis
afin d'être père
de tous ceux
qui croiraient
ok
verset 16
pardon
verset 11
des Romains
chapitre 4
on a aussi
plusieurs autres passages
qui parlent
explicitement
de l'inclusion
de toutes les nations
dans la Nouvelle Alliance
en démontrant
que c'était
les plans
d'origine
dès le départ
et en démontrant
qu'ils réjouissent
de cette promesse
dans les deux dispensations
donc 1ère pierre 2
9 et 10
vous au contraire
vous êtes une race élue
donc langage très similaire
à celui de Moïse
donc voilà pourquoi
l'implication
pour comprendre aussi
l'Alliance mosaïque
elle est très importante
pour ne pas retomber
sur la républication
des alliances
des œuvres
car cette communication
des grâces
et cette communication
de la promesse
de cette relation
avec Dieu
par grâce
elle est là
donc vous au contraire
vous êtes une race élue
un sacerdoce royal
une nation sainte
un peuple acquis
afin que vous vous annonciez
les vertus
de celui
qui vous appelait
des ténèbres
à son admirable lumière
vous qui autrefois
n'étiez pas un peuple
mais qui maintenant
êtes les peuples
des dieux
vous qui n'aviez pas
obtenu miséricorde
et qui maintenant
obtiennent miséricorde
voilà il y a plein
des textes
et la synthèse
principale
de Paul
dans cette conclusion
chapitre 3
7 à 9
des Galates
sachez donc
que ceux qui sont
de la foi
ceux-là
sont les fils d'Abraham
et les écritures
ayant vu
que Dieu
justifie par la foi
les gentils
ont annoncé
auparavant
Abraham
qu'en lui
toutes les nations
seraient bénies
donc c'est clair pour vous
c'est la même promesse
dans l'Ancien Testament
la même promesse
dans le Nouveau Testament
cette promesse
elle concerne
depuis l'Ancien Testament
toutes les peuples
des personnes
et tous les peuples
et elle concerne
ceux de la foi
dans la réalité
de l'expérience
de la réjouissance
car même si
Israël a réjoui
des bénédictions
temporelles
dans un cadre
d'alliances
temporelles
humaines
à partir
de la circoncision
la réalité
de la réjouissance
de l'amitié
avec Dieu
même dans l'Ancien Alliance
était réservée
qui est pour ceux
de la foi
ok
des questions
jusqu'ici
ok
j'avance
donc le deuxième point
c'est que la réjouissance
de ces bénédictions
sont les mêmes
dans l'Ancien
et dans les Nouveaux Testament
donc là
on pourrait citer
voilà
l'Epsom 51
où David parle
de la pureté
du coeur
que Dieu
renouvelle en lui
sa douleur
la joie
de son salut
et même
la réjouissance
des influences
de son esprit
comme des repères
pour nous
et nous avons
Romain chapitre 4
qui nous parle clairement
de cette foi
d'Abraham
cette foi
de David
et David
qui va inclure
dans plusieurs psaumes
qui est heureux
et l'homme
à qui Dieu
n'ampute pas
les péchés
c'est à dire
réjouissance réelle
des pardons
des péchés
réjouissance réelle
de ces réalités
qui nous réjouissons
aujourd'hui
donc c'est du même genre
c'est du même type
revenez sur Romain 4
pour que ça soit
bien clair pour vous
même si
c'est pas
de la même intensité
que ce que nous réjouissons
aujourd'hui
ok
donc lorsque
Jérémie
ou Ézéchiel
nous parlent
sur le fait
que Dieu
pardonnerait
dans le futur
nos offenses
c'est notamment
lié à quel point
il pardonnerait
jusqu'à déverser
son Saint-Esprit
mais ça ne veut pas dire
que cette intensité
supprime la réalité
de ce qu'ils ont pu
réjouir déjà
dans l'Ancien Testament
au contraire
on ne serait pas
voilà
encouragé
par leur témoignage
et je pense que
surtout
Hébreu chapitre 11
devrait suffire
pour qu'on voit
de quelle manière
cette nouée des témoins
sert pour nous
comme modèle
et repère
dans la foi
à plusieurs égards
et donc
la réjouissance
des mêmes bénédictions
dans l'Ancien
et dans le Nouveau Testament
les mêmes évangiles
sont prêchés
dans l'Ancien
et dans le Nouveau Testament
donc
je pense que
Galates chapitre 3
verset 8
c'est
voilà
les textes
les plus explicites
qui dit
que Dieu a prêché
l'évangile
à Abraham
en disant
que toutes les bénédictions
toutes les nations
seraient bénies
dans sa postérité
donc Paul
il veut vraiment
car c'est son explication
dans les passages
qu'on comprenne
que même si
Abraham n'avait pas
toute la compréhension
de comment
le Seigneur Jésus
viendraient
il savait
qu'en descendant
viendraient
et ses descendants
béniraient
toutes les nations
et Abraham a cru
et c'est là
lui a eu
amputé par justice
donc la manière
dont il a participé
au salut
c'était par la foi
dans la provision
future des dieux
mais
c'est les mêmes évangiles
qui a prêché
dans l'Ancien Testament
dans le Nouveau Testament
et ça
ça devrait être
encore plus clair
pour nous tous
si c'est les mêmes évangiles
prêchés
et là c'est à nouveau
très important
par rapport à la manière
dont on va faire
dont on va comprendre
l'alliance mosaïque
ok
ça c'est très important
pour nous
car même
envers Moïse
c'était
très explicite
que les mêmes évangiles
étaient prêchés
dans quel sens
nous ne pouvons pas lire
l'histoire de Moïse
car Dieu
dans toutes ses préparations
il était en train
de nous préparer
pour ne pas rater
l'évangile
lorsqu'on arrive
à la loi
qui est délivrée
à nouveau
c'est car
quand on voit
la manière dont
les Pâques
ont été établies
ou la Pâque
a été établie
on voit de manière
très claire
que Christ
était représenté
par l'agneau
c'est pas au hasard
que le Nouveau Testament
va réclamer
si tant de passages
et que même
les visages du Seigneur
dans la gloire future
soient les visages
d'un agneau
et où commence
cette histoire d'agneau
ça commence
par
depuis
les versements de sang
en Genèse
sans définition
clairement d'être
un agneau ou pas
mais surtout
par la richesse
de la grâce
de Dieu révélée
dans la révélation
du besoin exact
de quelle manière
nos fautes seraient expiées
et les langages
d'un agneau
innocent
qui devrait
recevoir sur lui
la punition
qu'on méritait
et donc
l'agneau des dieux
qui hâte
les péchés du monde
c'est un langage
très mosaïque
c'est très tabernacle
c'est très
loi cérémonielle
et donc
tous les types
qui nous voyons
dans les tabernacles
et plus tard
dans les temples
nous montrent clairement
de manière
encore plus profonde
quelle est la distance
entre Dieu
dans sa pureté
et l'homme
dans sa condition
et qui pourrait oser dire
que cela ne fait pas partie
de la grâce de Dieu
c'est notamment
la grâce de Dieu
pour nous convaincre
davantage
de la conviction
de nos péchés
ce qui mérite
nos péchés
et la distance absolue
entre un Dieu pur
et les êtres humains
qui nous prépare
le mieux
pour comprendre
la grâce de Dieu
révélé en Jésus-Christ
et donc
si on avait pas
si on avait
qu'est la loi
avec ces punitions
mais pas les provisions
pour les purifications
pour les sacrifices
on pourrait dire peut-être
que la loi mosaïque
était une loi
exclusivement des morts
une loi des œuvres
peut-être
mais la réalité
c'est que déjà
elle est donnée
après les Pâques
et elle est donnée
avec plein de provisions
!
par rapport
à l'expiation
de nos fautes
et elle est donnée
dans une relation
assez spectaculaire
dans le sens
de l'intimité
de la condescension
de Dieu
qui vient habiter
avec le peuple
d'abord dans les tentes
ensuite
dans les temples
et c'est
oui
Dieu sera
notre Dieu
et d'ailleurs
la description biblique
du sanctuaire céleste
un lieu encore plus excellent
qui est dans
et quand on pense
au tabernacle
ou au temple
on est en train d'imaginer
de quelle manière
on va pouvoir accéder
au trône de la grâce
de Dieu
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui a baptisé
l'arche de l'alliance
avec les propitiatoires
et les trônes
de la grâce
ou de la miséricorde
de Dieu
et donc comment
faire face
à l'alliance mosaïque
ou
oui
à l'alliance mosaïque
sans qu'on voit partout
la grâce de Dieu
dans l'encadrement
dans les histoires
dans les typologies
de l'évangile
qui sont là
et donc on va
de manière très claire
c'est
une alliance
qui était subserviente
à l'alliance
surtout
l'alliance explicite
avec Abraham
et donc
même si son emphase
particulière
c'était l'emphase
sur les péchés
donc c'est l'argument
de Paul
au chapitre 3
et là il dit
l'écriture
ayant vu
que Dieu justifie
par la foi
les païens
annonça auparavant
la bonne nouvelle
Abraham
toutes les nations
seront bénies
en lui
et donc
les mêmes évangiles
est prêché partout
nous voyons
non seulement
dans les alliances
établies
mais nous voyons aussi
dans toute l'histoire
de l'Ancien Testament
voilà l'arche de Noël
qui représentait
les Christ
qui lui va absorber
l'impact de la colère
de Dieu
pour nous protéger
on voit ça même
dans les poignets
de Moïse
on voit les Pâques
on voit les tabernacles
les sacrifices
les temples
on les voit
avec David et Goliath
dans Jonas
qui va ressusciter
le troisième jour
ou qui représente
la ressuriction du Christ
on les voit
en Esaïe 53
on voit les mêmes
évangiles prêchés
dans l'Ancien Testament
c'est très important
pour nous
de ne jamais
lire l'Ancien Testament
avec
cette emphase
très dispensationaliste
comme si on était
devant des ruptures
mais des éléments
qui Dieu a intentionnellement
établi
les longues de l'histoire
pour une fois
qu'on a saisi les Christ
on puisse s'approfondir
davantage
et encore mieux
comprendre les Christ
et notre relation
avec lui
ok
ensuite
le quatrième point
c'est la même
église spirituelle
ou les mêmes
peuples
si vous voulez
c'est un seul peuple
dans l'Alliance des Grâces
ça
et là je vais
ouvrir en parenthèse
dans vos études
sur la théologie
des alliances
c'est possible
que vous remarquiez
quelque chose
qui se passe
plutôt
un peu plus récent
dans nos jours
donc il y a eu
récemment
ce qu'on appelle
la popularisation
de la sotériologie
réformée
donc plusieurs
d'entre nous
nous sommes arrivés
à la fois réformés
en ayant
venu
ou en ayant débuté
dans des églises
qu'elles soient
baptistes
ou charismatiques
qui étaient plutôt
générales
arméniennes
ce qui caractérise
ces églises
arméniennes
de manière générale
c'est
une influence
particulière
d'une position
scatologique
qui est répandue
et en général
c'est une position
dispensationaliste
donc parfois
les personnes
elles arrivent
à embrasser
la foi
ou la sotériologie
réformée
mais parfois
il y a
des restes
de ces influences
dans leur scatologie
qui seront
peut-être
préservées
dans leurs études
plus larges
ou plus profondes
de la tradition
réformée
et donc je ne suis pas
en train de dire
que ces choses
jouent de manière
déterminante
dans la position
de chacun
mais il faut
qu'on soit
attentif
à ces choses
car aujourd'hui
la position
qui me semble
la plus populaire
entre les baptistes
réformés
c'est la position
qui est appelée
les fédéralistes
de 1689
et dans cette position
on va
plus comprendre
plus tard
leur portée
elle est plus
vers la rupture
entre les alliances
et à partir
de là
c'est une position
qui aura
ce qu'on appelle
une tendance
plus dispensationaliste
c'est-à-dire
de mettre
plus en phase
dans les ruptures
entre les alliances
et donc ici
nous sommes
devant
l'un des points
principaux
et capital
pour soutenir
ou détruire
cette position
car même si
on a plusieurs positions
qui sont légitimes
en termes
d'orthodoxie
si on peut dire
comme ça
elles ne sont pas
toutes défensables
également
par la parole
des dieux
et donc
si votre position
scatologique
et scatologique
elle est
plutôt dispensationaliste
vous dépendez
absolument
d'une vision
des deux peuples
deux peuples
des dieux
Israël
dans l'Ancien Testament
ok
et l'Église
dans le Nouveau Testament
une claire rupture
entre ces deux peuples
s'il y a beaucoup
par exemple
même si on n'a pas
tout clair
dans notre pensée
tous les systèmes
si vous notez
chez vous
une tendance
exagérée
à voir
Israël
encore aujourd'hui
comme les thermomètres
de l'histoire
c'est une tendance
dispensationaliste
qui peut
jouer
sur vos convictions
et votre compréhension
biblique
d'accord
et donc
ce qu'on va
comprendre
sur ces points
c'est que
la Bible
elle est claire
par rapport
à un seul peuple
sous deux dispensations
et les arguments
sont très intéressants
donc déjà
la promesse
explicite
faite à Abraham
c'était la promesse
qui concernait
surtout
et avant tout
déjà
même si pas très clair
à l'époque
les peuples
de la foi
c'est l'argument
de Paul
en Galat chapitre 3
que nous avons déjà lu
c'est à dire
même si
des implications
temporelles
secondaires
didactiques
typologiques
vont inclure
tout l'Israël biologique
l'argument de Paul
c'est
cette promesse
a été faite
à Abraham
roman 4
après sa foi
circoncision
comme un symbole
d'une foi
qui était déjà là
pour mettre
l'emphase
sur le fait
que la vraie
descendance
d'Abraham
est la descendance
de la foi
ok
à partir de là
toutes les nations
seraient bénies
dans les descendants
qui viendra
d'Abraham
et donc
notamment les Christs
et l'insistance
de Paul
explicite
sur plusieurs versets
qui nous dit
donc la vraie
postérité
d'Abraham
c'est
ceux de la foi
l'allégorie
de Sarah
et Agar
un autre passage
en Galate 4
Paul arrive
à point de dire
que
l'Israël
actuel
c'est
Agar
donc remarquez bien
à quel point
il arrive
pour faire
cette déclaration
l'Israël
actuel
est Agar
mais
voilà
verset
à 31
car Agar
elle est mon
Sinaïn
en Arabie
et elle
correspond
à la Jérusalem
actuelle
c'était quoi
la Jérusalem
actuelle
c'était la descendance
biologique
d'Abraham
c'était
Israël
c'était notamment
la descendance
biologique
d'Israël
d'Abraham
qui était considérée
comme
Agar
donc vous vous rappelez
l'allégorie
Agar
la femme
qui était
la servante
de Sarah
Sarah stérile
et les fruits
naturels
les fruits
des efforts
naturels
cherchant à saisir
les promesses de Dieu
par les efforts
par les oeuvres
etc
par statut
biologique
je suis fils
d'Abraham
selon la chair
et ça n'arrive pas
à embrasser
les réalités
spirituelles
mais la promesse
réelle
était faite
à Sarah
au fils légitime
sauf que Sarah
ne pouvait pas
avoir des enfants
donc
conclusion
que Dieu
peut engendrer
ses enfants
c'est à dire
les enfants réels
d'Abraham
les enfants spirituels
donc
la concrétisation
de la promesse
n'est pas
l'effet
qu'Abraham
a eu
en fils biologique
qui perpétuerait
sa postérité
biologiquement
c'était
les miracles
en soi
d'avoir un enfant
lorsqu'on ne pouvait pas
avoir d'enfant
c'est Dieu seul
qui aurait pu
les faire
et donc c'est à dire
totalement dépendant
de l'oeuvre des dieux
et de la foi
d'Abraham
voilà pourquoi
la descendance
attention
c'est qu'il peut être
en train de dire
la descendance biologique
d'Israël
si elle est contentée
qu'avec ça
elle est
la descendance
d'Agar
c'est à dire
ce sont les descendants
d'Isaac
tout simplement
des efforts biologiques
à partir d'Isaac
vous êtes avec moi ?
non d'Isaac
car en fait
l'Israël
actuel
est la descendance
biologique
à partir d'Isaac
avant Isaac
miracle des dieux
total
donc la mère
d'Isaac
quelque part
est la Jérusalem
d'en haut
c'est ce qu'il peut être
en train de dire
par contre
à partir d'Isaac
la descendance
d'Israël
n'est qu'ébiologique
à moins qu'on retrouve
ceux de la foi
là-dedans
mais la descendance
qui est biologique
d'Israël
Paul est en train de dire
c'est Agar
pourquoi ?
à cette époque
Israël était
esclave
dominée
par les romans
et ce qu'il est en train
de dire
c'est la conséquence
sera toujours la même
tant que les Israéliens
ethniques
pensent qu'ils seraient bénis
jusqu'à son enfant
d'Abraham
c'est perdu
ils sont à nouveau
dans la dynamique
de cette solution
fausse
envers Agar
vous avez compris
l'argument de Paul
donc ce que Paul
est en train de dire
c'est que la vraie descendance
est celle qui a pour mère
la Jérusalem
et il va conclure
ce passage
en disant
ainsi donc frère
nous ne sommes pas
enfants de la servante
mais de la libre
et il est en train
de dire ça
aux Galates
c'est-à-dire aux païens
à ceux qui ne sont pas
juifs de naissance
donc là
ça montre clairement
que les peuples
ont toujours été
les mêmes
pour ce qui concerne
l'aspect spirituel
de la réalité
de ces alliances
l'inclusion
des gentils
et l'unité
en Christ
elle est partout
affichée
dans la Bible
Ephésiens
chapitre 2
11 à 13
verset 19
c'est pourquoi rappelez-vous
que vous qui étiez
autrefois
des païens dans la chair
appelés un circoncise
par ce qui s'appelle
circoncision
c'est-à-dire
ce qui s'appelle
circoncision
c'est la circoncision
biologique
ethnique
charnelle
mais la vraie circoncision
donc faite par les membres
souvenez-vous
que vous étiez
sans Christ
exclu de la citoyenneté
d'Israël
étranger aux alliances
de la promesse
n'ayant aucun espoir
et sans Dieu
dans les mondes
mais maintenant
Jésus-Christ
vous qui étiez
autrefois loin
vous êtes approché
par les sains de Jésus
ainsi donc
vous n'êtes plus
des étrangers
et des gens de dehors
mais vous êtes
concitoyens des
gens de la maison
des dieux
donc quel est
le langage ici
ou l'objectif ici
c'est de dire
avec les Galates
qui depuis le début
les païens
étaient inclus
et aujourd'hui
dans l'histoire
c'est les cas
la nouvelle alliance
vient confirmer
cet idéal des dieux
depuis le début
donc c'est une alliance
pardon
c'est une assurance
et une promesse
unique
telle qu'est révélée
en hébreu
chapitre 6
verset 13
et 18
afin que vous ne soyez
pas paresseux
mais que vous imitiez
ceux qui par la foi
et la patience
héritent les promesses
car lorsque Dieu
a fait la promesse
à Abraham
n'ayant pas plus grand
pour jurer
il a juré pour soi-même
afin que par deux choses
immuables
dans lesquelles
il est impossible
que Dieu mente
nous ayons
un ferme encouragement
nous qui avons cherché
le refuge
qui nous est proposé
et donc
lorsque Dieu
fit la promesse
à Abraham
il a fait
la promesse
qui inclurait
déjà
avec assurance
même ceux
qui ont
la descendance
de la foi d'Abraham
et l'illustration
de l'Olivier
qui est évidente
en Rome
en chapitre 11
c'est étonnant
de chercher
à insister
sur deux peuples
Israël
comme si
jusqu'aujourd'hui
ils étaient encore
dans l'attente
que certains
accomplissements
soient réservés
pour eux
réjouiqués par eux
dans une réjouissance
du Rome
des dieux
ou du christianisme
comme s'il était
différent de nous
donc l'illustration
de l'Olivier
il est clair
donc il y avait
une progression
dans la révélation
de l'Evangile
dans les peuples
de l'Ancien Testament
ceux qui n'étaient pas
les vrais peuples
de la foi
ont été étranchés
et une fois
que Christ est arrivé
nous avons été greffés
dans ces mêmes
oliviers
ok
donc c'est les mêmes peuples
on est connecté
au vrai peuple
ok
mais
il reste encore
de la possibilité
que les juifs
biologiques aujourd'hui
soient greffés
et il serait peut-être
encore plus facilement
greffés
dans l'essence
de l'illustration
si
il se répand
et s'il croit
sauf que
s'ils ne sont pas
les vrais peuples
qui est celui
de la foi
d'Abraham
s'ils sont qu'ils
de la descendance
d'Abraham
ils ne sont pas
les vrais peuples
et donc nous
on doit être
dans cette dynamique
nous sommes les vrais peuples
greffés à l'olivier
ok
aux vrais chrétiens
de l'Ancien Testament
mais c'est un seul peuple
continuité
évidente
et d'autres arguments
qui sont centrés
sur la réjouissance
des sangs
aujourd'hui
des mêmes
bénédictions célestes
qui nous réjouissons
donc là
nous sommes
Jésus lui-même
veut dire
vous verrez
Abraham
Isaac
et Jacob
et tous les prophètes
dans les royaumes
des dieux
et vous serez
j'étais
dehors
donc
qu'est-ce que
Christ est en train
de dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
même
Abraham
Isaac
et Jacob
et tous les prophètes
sont déjà
dans les royaumes
des dieux
ils sont déjà
en train de réjouir
des royaumes
des dieux
ils ne sont pas
dans l'attente
d'un autre type
des royaumes
et pourquoi
nous pouvons affirmer ça
avec encore plus
de certitude
il suffit d'aller vers Hébreux
où ils nous montrent
que déjà
ils sont en train
de mettre en emphase
leur foi
et leur foi
comme prouvant
qu'en étant détachés
et n'est pas touchant
les choses
pendant leur vie sur terre
ils étaient en train
d'envisager
quelque chose
de supérieur
la Jérusalem
céleste
et donc
cette réjouissance
du royaume
des dieux
est déjà
la même réalité
que nous nous réjouissons
depuis qu'Christ
a été entronisé
et qu'ils réjouissent
déjà
des manières
spirituelles
dans les lieux célestes
car eux
ils attendaient
la cité
ayant des solides
fondements
celles dont Dieu
est l'architecte
et constructeur
et tout cela
ces personnes-là
ayant obtenu
par la foi
un bon témoignage
n'ont pas reçu
la promesse
de Dieu
pardon
non pas reçu
la promesse
Dieu
ayant réservé
quelque chose
de meilleur
pour nous
afin qu'il
ne parvienne
pas sans nous
à la perfection
donc il parvient
avec nous
en Christ
mais nous
avec eux
dans la perfection
du Christ
nous n'attendons
plus
aucune chose
plus parfaite
ou plus inférieure
ou moins
en spirituel
vous vous êtes
approché
de Sion
Hébreu 12
de la ville
du Dieu vivant
de Jérusalem
céleste
des myriades
d'anges
donc réalité
actuelle
Jérusalem
céleste
myriades
d'anges
l'assemblée
des premiers-nés
qui sont
ces premiers-nés
c'est cette nouée
des témoins
dont on est en train
de parler
ils sont
les premiers-nés
qui sont inscrits
dans les cieux
des dieux
les juges
de tous
et des esprits
des justes
parvenus à la perfection
et des Jésus
médiateurs
d'une alliance
nouvelle
donc ils sont
déjà en train
de réjouir
de l'alliance
nouvelle
il n'y a pas
une alliance
nouvelle
point A
ou point B
exclusive
pour les juifs
mais ils sont
dans l'alliance
nouvelle
et du sang
de l'aspersion
qui parle mieux
que celui d'Abel
inclus dans
l'alliance
nouvelle
inclus dans
l'alliance
ils ne sont pas
une classe
réservée
dans l'Ancien Testament
nous allons devoir
nous arrêter ici
et les derniers points
c'était
les mêmes moyens
d'appropriation
de salut
je peux vous partager
après mais
on voit clairement
que c'était par la foi
qu'ils aient été justifiés
Hébreu 11
comme je viens de mentionner
par la foi
et les mêmes
seuls médiateurs
on va revenir
sur ces points
quand on parlera
de ces mystères glorieux
mais c'est toujours
les fils des dieux
incarnés
qui a toujours été
les médiateurs
dans l'Ancien Testament
et dans les Nouveaux Testaments
donc les mêmes médiateurs
et ces points-là
ce sont les points
qui montrent
qu'il s'agit
d'une seule alliance
des grâces
qui a été